let me set this up for people who don't
know he's waiting in the wings he's kind
of a likes guts that he's a mini
celebrity here yes hashtag day without
immigrant to protest by the way if
you're if you're not going to show up to
work that's not to tip them off told
them don't see the day off we need you
and then they decided to take the day
off and then he terminated 30 people all
right you're out he said I have gone
above and beyond for these people no one
is going to dictate how my company is
run somebody there we go
this is Jim zorroski thank you for being
with us sir thank you very much
appreciate being here Jim it seems the
problem here was not that people just
didn't show up because someone was sick
but they notified you they weren't going
to show up in protest
now I've had jobs myself where if I told
them I'm not gonna work tomorrow and
they said you have to work I would
anticipate being fired and we're out of
line there no not at all because you
know what I've raised my two girls I
worked seven days a week until my
fingers were bleeding and I couldn't lay
another brick and I wouldn't miss a day
of work because I had to support my
family did that's my stance on that well
so do these people did they tell you
beforehand they weren't because I know
there was there was a trend everyone was
talking about it did they say hey we're
not going to show up to work in protest
and he had a conversation with him I did
get a phone call from the foreman who
orchestrated the whole thing it wasn't
all the guys on the jobs that just
decided they were going to walk off it
was the formants that shut the job down
and I told him I says you know if you
take the day off you're gonna be fired
and then they took that as a maybe it's
pretty simple they thought well this
didn't start out as just one incidence
this will spit has been building up
they've been dictating to my my wages
that I've been paying down by make it
scandalous remarks and stuff
yeah and but I take care of my guys very
well and I and I love them it comes down
to that they turned her back on me as
far as I'm concerned I mean I've done
nothing but support every each and every
one of them because
I know what it is to work in the field
and work so hard right it it was
devastating to me for them to take they
got and I have five six other jobs going
on that they all worked right yeah all
still working well so have you replaced
these people yet or is that a whole
process no I replace them all quickly so
I make yeah well that's the reason you
are Jim zorroski so has the feedback
been mostly positive or mostly negative
I got all kinds of different negative I
mean every phone call I got was negative
now it's starting to become 50/50 yeah
well I think that's just because I think
there's sort of a fuse on that a long
fuse because the media tends to lean
left and it might take a while for for
people like us to to actually get a hold
of you as a matter of fact there were
other people who did this to Jim and our
Booker was calling on the list and they
just said listen this has become such a
crap show I've gotten so many threats I
I don't want to talk about it and they
were afraid and you were the only one
who who sacked on up to the plate so we
appreciate it well I appreciate you take
it giving me the opportunity because you
know what a lot of people died for this
country and I I feel the same way I mean
I have the utmost respect for two
veterans to died for this country and
and the ones who searched for this
country and I thought it was very
disrespectful for somebody to turn
around say we're taking a day off
because you need us right well that's
that sad seems like very very gracious
of you well you know I may have a few
small business owner and Gerald yet in
that quite a bit
how would you react to this I would
react the same way my dad owns a
construction company and you've got a
timeline to keep right people are
pressuring you to get stuff done you've
got material costs and all kinds of
things you don't get checks until you
get done right and you're gonna take a
day off and cost me money for no good
reason
so yes right baby I am paying every
government entity there is it ahead of
time before I get paid right which is a
bit of a rule the fastest 90 days yeah
right yes so I am literally funding not
only the
people are working for JVs but I'm
funding the government yeah yeah well
you're funding the government who often
a lot of these unions give giant
kickbacks to in order to give them
favorable laws as well so it's a
never-ending racket right it's all right
join the Union what if I don't want to
do anything well you're in a state where
you have to join the union
okay now the union's gonna support this
Democratic candidate for president who's
gonna create pro union laws but and then
this happens do you feel do you feel
angst at all or sort of are you upset
with the political climate that created
this you know this is a result of the
political climate where there's this
classism right it's it's the top one
percent well most people don't realize
almost all businesses the United States
put you in the top one percent you know
people don't understand that if they
look at the way businesses businesses
are taxed is there a part of you that
goes like gosh you know I just want to
create jobs and make an honest living
and not have to deal with the political
climate that is everywhere now that's a
very good question it's uh you know I
don't do this for myself right did I do
this for my family right and I've done
this for my family and I have the utmost
respect for everybody in the field
that's gonna work as hard as I did right
that's what it comes down to it's not
about you know sure I enjoy perks now
and again but sure it's you know yeah
that's none of anyone's business listen
I if you make a good living so much the
better
and a lot of business owners have they
like Gerald knows a lot of them struggle
to make any living often certainly in
the first few years you're paying
employs more than you're taking as a
business owner that feels really weird
it's almost truth I can't tell you how
much I struggled to start this company I
mean I was banging my head on the desk
at night at 11 o'clock because I was so
tired because I was driving truck I was
laying brick I was estimating and people
want estimates for me and and I just got
so tired that I just bang my head on the
desk going oh my god why am I doing this
you hear that's tax him that's a lot of
privilege going
a lot of privilege going on a disk yeah
yeah well by the way banging head in the
desk let's keep that to a minimum that's
not necessarily good for longevity you
have a lot more other employees to worry
about that's what my psychiatrist says
yeah exactly until until until the
employees don't show up and you can't
fill the Psychiatry bill and they say
let me help you go ahead right there
stop the case no I have no because I
care about that right well that's most
business owners again they assume this
motive that it's like you know you're
just scrooge mcduck jumping into a pile
of gold let me ask you how many people
do you employ total at your head your
company between 90 and 100 at this point
after the other day 60 to 70 okay that's
a big joke about mccarroll I started
from nothing yeah absolutely nothing
gosh that's that well it's it's it's an
odd time in history where at one point
we'd be having gym on just as an
interview you know or any news channel
we'll just as an American success story
hey look white picket fence American
Dream this guy went out he made an
honest buck he worked hard and now he's
you know he's enjoying the fruits of his
labor instead nowadays the first two are
you hear is big evil business owner who
laid off people who decided not this job
to work that's crazy
that you know that wasn't it it was
bottom line is you know I said care of
you guys I support you guys so I took it
personal for you not to show up sure
because you look you hurt me because I'm
the one that has to bottom line deal
with the contractual obligations yeah
I'm the one that has I have my name on
it right well that's a productive
mindset versus the mindset of someone
who actually it can be really selfish
the lack of consideration for other
people in the company or the people who
employ there's a certain amount of irony
in let's let's protest to see how you
can live without me and then they
rehired new people the next day
I mean you guys hit that right on the
head - yeah you don't you're yeah I'm
pretty resilient I'm not gonna I'm not
gonna give in to somebody's yeah they're
going to could they are going to shut
America down yeah for today right and
that's that you are going against
everything that I was raised upon yeah
and I believe you're not the blood when
I'm at 100% pure polish both my
grandparents came over from Poland and
you know what they did nothing but teach
me how to be an American
yeah it's to respect it well to honor it
well that's a good point I mean listen
people came and people say we're a
nation of immigrants actually no we're a
nation of people who came from other
countries to become Americans when
you're here you're no longer an
immigrant you're an American and that's
the beauty of a cultural melting pot hey
one thing to keep an eye out though we
do have to go Jim there is going to be
day hashtag day without women so if you
have any female employees a mag free day
like this video subscribe by clicking
the button that says subscribe if you're
not aware of it now there's no way
you're learning the internet at this
point I'm not going to help you but this
was clipped from my daily show available
exclusively to lotto with credit com /
mug club members of your student
military or veteran internet promo code
it's less than six dollars a month and
you get daily content no more clips Plus
this hand etched mug
oh I just when I feel it I got a chill
like on the inside